[Music]
well rent prices like everything
continue to climb and for many seniors
it's an issue that could leave many out
in the cold thank you for joining us at
11 I'm Brian Loftus eight news now
viewers coming forward with challenges
that they are facing reporter Brian will
visiting one of those seniors affected
and tells us what their options are
Brian
good evening Brian this piece of land
I'm standing on was given to Clark
County to build affordable housing for
seniors but for some it may not come
soon enough
just this past rent increase was 150
bucks
and one before that was a little less
but the 150 bucks is the one that hurts
Judy proschek and her husband have lived
in this apartment since it opened 30
years ago she is one of the many seniors
on a fixed income uncertain how she can
afford to live there much longer I don't
know how many more times I can keep
signing the lease
if it keeps going up that much each time
proshek does not receive any rental
assistance and programs like chap have
been drastically scaled back as rent
continues to climb from the first
quarter of 2019 through the second
quarter of 2022 market rate rate rent in
Las Vegas increased by 33.1 percent now
an assembly bill could help people like
Pro Shack assembly Bill 396 makes an
appropriation of 22 million dollars to
Clark County for programs for rental
assistance in each fiscal year that bill
if approved would make funds available
on July 1st in the meantime Clark County
is also trying to help approving 120
million dollars for their community
housing fund but it's a problem that
doesn't have a quick solution I don't
see it going down I really don't I don't
see it going down I just hope it it next
year when the lease comes it don't jump
another 150 bucks because it's just hard
this Housing Development won't be ready
until 2025. the good news is more of
these developments will be going up
across the county reporting live by
Eastern and Pebble Brian will eight news
now